jean-gérard vespière merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur rt france le
premier ministre irakien devait donc se
rendre aujourd'hui à ryad alors qu'on
vient d'apprendre l'hospitalisation du
roi salman mais quel était le but de
cette rencontre est de rendre compte de
consolider de maintenir les liens qui
existent entre l'irak et l'arabie
saoudite
lorsque la première visite d'un premier
ministre irakien ariane remonte à
octobre 2014 n'est ce pas donc il y a
déjà une longue histoire dans la
coopération entre l'irak et l'arabie
saoudite il existe une commission à de
développement conjointe donc donc entre
le l'irak et l'arabie saoudite
il y à des échanges réguliers entre les
deux pays et cela représente bon une
évolution un excuse moi dans la bonne
position historique de l'irak qui a été
a quand même très proches toujours de
l'iran depuis quelques années donc il ya
un jeu d'équilibré qui essaye d'être
mise en place par le gouvernement
central de bagdad leroy salmagne qui est
donc hospitalisé aujourd'hui il est âgé
de 84 ans il est donc âgé s'il venait à
décéder quelles seraient les
conséquences dans la région écoutez tout
cela est déjà prévue n'est ce pas parce
que le prince héritier serait
normalement le fameux le célèbre mbs
mohammed bin salman
donc il y a déjà une politique mise en
place par donc le roi salman et son fils
- bell bell salman depuis maintenant
plus de cinq ans donc il n'y a pas à mon
avis un sauf soubresauts en arabie
saoudite 1 2
changement à prévoir on l'a dit un
rencontre hier entre les chefs de la
diplomatie irakienne ou iranienne
comment est-ce qu'il faut qualifier la
relation entre bagdad et téhéran
l'écouté elle est de deux points de vue
à un il faut regarder d'abord les
institutions donc le rapport entre les
autorités et puis deuxièmement la
population donc en ce qui concerne les
échanges entre les rencontres entre les
dirigeants et bien il y a toujours le
même niveau effectivement les fréquences
de rencontre par contre au niveau de la
population irakienne nous avons vu en
2018 mais manifestations dans le sud à
bassora
parce qu'il y avait des gros problèmes
de ressources en eau et à cette époque
et bien il ya eu incendie du consulat
iranien à bassorah le drapeau iranien a
été brûlée et cats ont vu en 2019 à
bagdad à bassora nouveau et bien des
foules dans la rue dire iran dehors
n'est ce pas et donc il n'ya au niveau
de la population un ressentiment qui
commence à naître un contre sept alliés
et ennemis à iranien qui entretient il
faut le savoir
trente mille un milicien 30-35 miliciens
qui sont payés tous les mois donc
irakiens qui sont payés tous les mois
par le trésor iranien nessma est donc
cette organisation set m'a mise politico
militaire aux problèmes et cette
rencontre d'hier la première du genre
depuis l'assassinât du général iranien
soleimani par les américains l'extérieur
de l'aéroport de bagdad est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre à de nouveaux
affrontements entre l'iran et les états
unis
notamment sur le sol irakien a je crois
pas je pencherais plutôt vers le
contraire parce que voyez-vous après
l'élimination du général sur les manic
qui a été quand même une opération
exceptionnelle par le niveau des
responsabilités de ce général au niveau
du système politico militaire iranien
numéro 2 numéro trois du régime n'est ce
pas qu aurait réagi comme anvers est
régi les états unis si le numéro 2
numéro trois du système politico
militaires américains avaient été
assassinés par des iraniens dont on
n'ose pas y penser
donc l'arrêt la réaction iranienne a été
relativement faible et il y a eu à la
suite de cela des tirs de missiles sur
les bases iranienne sans faire de morts
et des fera dans les alentours de
l'ambassade ira à mary kerr à bagdad
mais qui ont cessé depuis quelques
semaines parce que le pouvoir a mis le
pouvoir central de bagdad à est
intervenue elle a mis quelques jours en
prison certains des membres des milices
qui avait fait ses opérations de
lancement de d'obus de mortier dans les
alentours de l'ambassade américaine donc
il y à un apaisement dans les relations
triangulaires irakienne américaine
iranienne merci gérard vespière d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient